fast 100 minuten spielen freiburg und
der fc bayern am ende stehen jedoch ein
paar sekunden im fokus nach knapp einer
stunde bringt leon goretzka die gäste in
führung in seiner ersten partie von
beginn an nach langer verletzungspause
jetzt startet die phase der
entscheidenden sekunden nils petersen
wird eingewechselt trifft 17 sekunden
später zum ausgleich seit 100 treffer
für den sportclub nicht ganz so fix aber
beinahe ist auch sehr schön aber nach
seiner einwechslung er braucht 33
sekunden dann stets eins zu zwei die 82
10 minute kingsley kommen mit einer
starken aktion ballannahme und abschluss
wie aus einem guss die bayern erhöhen
und jetzt wird es kurios der fcb
wechselt sabitzer ein aber keiner geht
raus knapp 20 sekunden stehen die
münchner mit einem spieler zu viel auf
dem platz nagelsmann zählt noch mal
durch und stellt fest hoppla wir sind zu
zwölft command geht also raus es wird
hin und her diskutiert dann geht's
weiter acht minuten werden deshalb nach
gespielt in denen trifft der
eingewechselte sabitzer zum endstand 1
zu 4 sein erstes tor für die bayern doch
am ende redet jeder nur über den
münchner wechsel tina
in dortmund geht es auch um den zwölften
mann hier allerdings zum glück um die
fans über 80.000 zuschauer gegen leipzig
ins stadion zum ersten mal nach 763
tagen und dann läuft nicht rund beim bvb
leipzig geht durch einen doppelpack von
konrad laimer in führung erst schließt
er mitgefühl ab dann landet der ball mit
etwas glück im netz im rittern fälscht
unhaltbar ab nach der pause erhöhen die
gäste und wieder ist laimer mittendrin
diesmal als vorbereiter für christopher
in kongo das 0 3 bitter für den bvb der
durch daniel mahlen zwar auch noch einen
treffer erzielt aber kurz vor schluss
einen weiteren hinnehmen muss daniel mit
dem schönsten tor des spiels zum
14 deshalb darf er auch mit aufs elfi
von matchwinner konrad liner der mit
zwei toren und einer vorlage
das kann man schon mal verteilt erst
spielte die hertha mit felix magath
zuvor war er wegen corona ja nicht mit
dabei und die partie endet ohne punkte
für die berlin leverkusen mit einem
doppelschlag erst lucas barrio in der 35
minute tolles tor dann stellt karim
bellarabi das ergebnis auf 2 0 die
berliner kommen zwar vor der pause noch
mal ran wladimir bary damit dem
anschlusstreffer doch weil in hälfte
zwei nichts mehr passiert fährt bayer
drei punkte ein und die härter mit
leeren händen nach hause
schneefall schöne tore und durchaus eine
kleine überraschung gibt zwischen der
tsg hoffenheim und dem vfl bochum die
gäste gehen durch ein schönes tor von
takuma sato in führung strammer schuss
des japaners
nach der pause ein nicht weniger schöner
treffer für hoffenheim david raum 54
minute mit ganz viel gefühl zum eins zu
eins
nur fünf minuten später taucht aber
erneut sano vor dem tsg tor auf und zwar
komplett allein das 1 2 nach knapp einer
stunde
der endstand buchen jubelt hoffenheim
verliert zuhause und verpasste es an
freiburg vorbeizuziehen
flutlicht an der alten försterei das
freitagsspiel union berlin gegen den
ersten fc köln die eisernen gewannen mit
1 0 das tor des abends erzielte
boni erst der aussetzer von jonas hector
dann macht der nigerianer kurzen prozess
saisontor nummer 12 für
union überholt die kölner damit in der
tabelle
eintracht frankfurt erst gegen für dann
gegen barcelona eine woche der
gegensätze gegen den tabellenletzten der
bundesliga fallen keine tore weil beide
teams großchancen liegen lassen brand in
gotha für das kleeblatt
constantia für die 1 50
danach wird tragisch eine schwere
knöchelverletzung erleidet marco
mayerhöfer schlimme szenen in frankfurt
der vierte wird noch am samstagabend
operiert und für eine lange zeit
ausfallen das ergebnis des spiels danach
nur noch zweitrangig
bielefeld gegen stuttgart auch hier wird
das spiel von einer schweren verletzung
überschattet sascha karadzic als sofort
mit der trage zur hilfe denn das ist
passiert fabian klos breit in der
nachspielzeit mit seinem team kollegen
alessandro schöpf zusammen er muss vom
platz getragen werden und wird seinem
team laut vereinsangaben für unbestimmte
zeit fehlen
[Applaus]
zurück zum sportlichen in hälfte eins
handspiel von patrick wimmer der vr
entscheidet elfmeter karadzic das 1 0
nach knapp einer stunde kommt die
arminia zum ausgleich florian krüger mit
seinem ersten saisontreffer stuttgart
insgesamt das bessere team doch es
bleibt beim 1 1
viel los im augsburger strafraum das
allerdings nur vor der partie gegen
wolfsburg denn während des spiels geht
es nur in eine richtung in die der gäste
erste minute führung für den fca der
brasilianer tiago mit einem schönen
schlenzer
nach etwas über einer stunde erhöhte
florian niederlechner auf zwei zu null
sieg artistisch aus und das ist es auch
er schießt sich selbst ins gesicht etwas
unkonventionell aber zählt natürlich
trotzdem für den schlusspunkt ist matt
petersen zuständig er trifft nach einer
tollen kombination des fca zum entstand
die schwaben holen drei richtige big
points im abstiegskampf und sind
dementsprechend in partylaune
die letzte partie am sonntagabend
borussia mönchengladbach gegen mainz 05
und die beginnt mit einem wunderbar
herausgespielten treffer erholen brembo
fünftes saisontor
mainz versucht alles aber scheitert
häufig ab überragenden jan sommer ein
unglaublicher reflex des schweizers nach
73 minuten ist aber auch er machtlos
karim o niveau mit dem ausgleich kurz
vor schluss um ein haar die führung für
mainz doch erneut steht sommer im weg
und das gleich zweimal ganz knappe
geschichte aber kein tor damit bleibt
beim 1 1
die ergebnisse des 28 spieltag es gibt
drei heim- und drei auswärtssiege dazu
drei unentschieden alles nach zahlen
gerecht aufgeteilt die torreichsten
spiele mit bayern und dortmund
beteiligung jeweils fünf treffer in den
beiden partien
und so wirkt sich das auf die tabelle
aus der bvb neun punkte hinter den
münchnern die hoffen müssen dass
freiburg keinen protest einlegt
insgesamt wenig bewegung in der oberen
hälfte nur union berlin verbessert sich
auf platz sieben im abstiegskampf geht
es richtig eng zu bielefeld und hertha
bsc tauschen plätze die berliner damit
wieder auf einem direkten abstiegsplatz
augsburg verbessert sich auf rang 14 und
das mit einer partie weniger das
nachholspiel gegen mainz findet am
kommenden mittwoch statt
[Musik]